welcome to this video playing a chess
game he just came from Finland and or
something else yeah let's do something
else probably allowing the grandfather
now ok just want some variety this
sometimes called the similar variation
against the against the Kings Indian
very a solid way to play why does just
um trying to play form with with good
development and good central control
yeah the double fianchetto is a somewhat
too rare set up against it really yeah
not so sure what is what is ideas I will
play for okay I know I know I really
play here for I was I went with age
three first to have Bishop e3 handy so
that 94 is not coming isn't this just a
good Kings Indian he's got bishop on b7
and then since think slender things like
that okay so i can't retreat here night
my god bishop f1 and then g3 kicking it
out
now the bishop on b7 is just really
really sticking out like a sore thumb
okay so who even night h4 comes into
consideration but I can really also just
start start that would operation here f5
is not working due to multiple things
mostly taking a 95 I guess should I yeah
is playing it anyway yeah maybe due to
this f4 idea like a form
yeah maybe I should have thought about a
bit longer because he just needs a
little bit of positioner black it's just
lost yet and maybe I'm maybe this this
before wasn't really good hmm ok
yeah before was very stupid and no only
even weakens the diagonal right he's got
all pieces misplace b6 and so on so yeah
I was really unnecessary I know I go
nudge five again and blackest black is
on the ropes yeah maybe you didn't have
anything else I don't know come to e6
now
okay just go to a 64 one hmm I don't
know and there are some technical tricks
with a silly-looking bishop young like
90 x 90 x squared X Queenie six and then
oops but I can first improve this a bit
I get you for anyway
96 oh yeah can we keep it simple this is
also just good
to try to not fall so much behind here
because new things this is one of those
very painful experiences would be lets
say i really hope i'm not losing it but
them okay just take him this is also
also possible increasing control over d5
yeah how do i take it's both interesting
yeah yeah it's it's both good am
rook takes 95 Bishop takes 95 it sir
just not easy for him to even keep
material yeah this losses in exchange
yeah I look this is a whole look I think
black reasons yeah I was on that that
really led to a terrible kings in the
end position but I was really I was just
them now here when he played this g3 is
good but before before really was now I
mean it is the hits even the move that
the computer is giving but I should have
thought a moment here to really think
about what about this f5 move it is some
hockey the computer is totally refuting
it but still it was a it was unpleasant
that I didn't really have already made
answer him the competition not do that
takes and place here yeah and of course
this is much better because he still
cannot player for its made on age seven
silly gap and okay bishop age six is the
comp line and then just this and 1.5 m I
mean this is this is a disaster okay it
was much stronger even Bishop t2 wasn't
the best but after this everything's I
think back begging or no y term White
has a substantial edge champ and yet
it's very difficult i mean this is just
all week offside night Dwight is
starting to get his stuff coordinated I
could have only played better yay rc5 a
strong interesting move we're on this
with this kind of this kind of idea it's
very strong
yeah it was even stronger than the game
but the way it went I have one material
here he good or bad had to go for this
then i can i can just take him and
dark-haired still needs to be one but
what is winning torn up and i have this
this excellent square on d5 okay thanks
for watching